hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen mode
review ich weiß die letzte mode reviews
sehr lange her aber ich habe mir auch
ein wenig gedanken gemacht bei den
nächsten mord den ich jetzt vorstelle
da ich jetzt nicht so ein mord
vorstellen wollte der vielleicht ein
paar items hinzufügt oder so oder eine
neue funktion irgendwie sowas sondern
das sollte schon etwas mehr sein und
zwar habe ich da an diesem ort gedacht
als ich habe eben kurz 25 gewechselt
oder f8 muss weg also das ist der extra
beim six ellrott sag ich mal so er ist
schon für die minecraft 1.215 4.2
updated was ich jetzt nicht zeigen
wollte dass es hier unten steht stets
dabei nicht mehr
ich dachte man das steht da ja gut um
den zu installieren braucht der forge
bot dazu werde ich vielleicht bald ein
tutorial machen wie man den ganz einfach
installiert den fortschritt das
eigentlich relativ einfach und dann
dieses extra bei uns xl dem motto der
steht alles in der beschreibung also da
einfach mal vorbeischauen und zwar was
macht dieser mod eigentlich genau das
wollten aussagen dieser mod fügt nämlich
extra biome hinzu wie schon im titel
steht von diesem video und zwar hier zb
1 bio stein ist keiner mehr ganz kurzen
stack speck ändern damit es vielleicht
auch ein bisschen sieht nehmen wir mal
poster kraft aufbauen aufbauen so poster
kopf zum beispiel hier ist und action
pack wird extra dabei ums xl supported
also da gibt es wirklich verschiedene
texte packs wie zb extra poster kraft
gibt es gibt null weg es gibt 6 ppg
kreft das default action pack sommer
viel es gibt ja echt zum party steht auf
der website von ihnen vorgeschlagen
welche das supporten ich nehme jetzt
einfach mal dass hier an diesem ort
vorzustellen und zwar gibt es ein extra
bis xl halt verschiedene biome warte ich
nimm doch mal das andere täglich nimmt
einfach mal default damit ihr das auch
alle erkennt also ihr seht hier schon
das erste bio dass es eigentlich wie
eine wüste oder eine ganz normale flache
landschaft mit ein paar kügelchen halt
alles nur in einer farbe wir haben hier
wirklich so einen blog der sich anhalt
als werkstein und der ein wenig so
aussieht als wäre es einfach eine rote
erde ab es ist ein kenner ganz normal
abbauen wenn ich irgendwie im zweifel
muss also und na ja also das ist halt
das erste extra vision hier sind auch so
komische gras teile wie halt in der
wüste diese komischen brown teil liegt
er manchmal rumstehen
oder halt im normalen im normalen in der
normalen landschaft sage ich mal im
flatland dies ist ganz normale gras ich
zeige euch das ganze gleich nochmal
survival mode ich habe jetzt in diesem
platz gewährt um den ort vorzustellen
weil ja echt zum aufeinandertreffen
wie schon gesagt hier haben wir so eine
kleine sache mal steinlandschaft also
ihr hört schon das ist halt ganz normal
stein nur hier sind es halt nicht
überall schnee und eigentlich tritt
schnell hauptsächlich in ganz normalen
ich sag mal erdregionen auf allerdings
ist das hier halt ganz normal auf stein
der ganze schnee hier haben wir dann
diese komischen fichten bäume das soll
aber nicht normale fichten bäume sondern
die sind einfach mal extrem groß ist
einfach viel größer
davon haben wir hier auch seinen bio da
können auch pilze darauf wachsen wie ihr
da oben seht also da können ja halt auch
pilze darauf wachsen und hier gilt zum
beispiel auch einfluss durch in dieser
stelle finde ich besonders schön hier
da sieht man wirklich echt diese hohen
bäume wenn man so reinkommt sieht man da
hinten noch das ende von dem anderen und
das ist echt schön was dieser mann
wirklich für landschaften den zug vor
allem für leute die gerne cinematics
machen bestimmt ein tolles feature sag
ich mal hier sind extrem viele schweine
na ja also das ist einfach ein ganz
normales hat das ist ja da muss man
aufpassen
aufpassen na ja also das sind wirklich
diese richtig richtig hohen bäumen echt
krass wenn dann mal so hoch guckt also
dieser baum hier zum beispiel das ist
fast so lang wie mein und so wissen wir
wissen bescheid
naja egal was ich euch auch noch zeigen
wollte ist davon vom da komme ich und
zwar an ich wollte etwas er ganz kurz
erstmal im zweifel mortier zeigen was
passiert wenn ich dass der abbau werde
da wo ich mich eben eine spitzhacke also
wie gesagt bei diesem motto kann man
natürlich viel erzählen alle viel zeigen
aber nicht allzu viel erzählen was
welche sagen nicht game mode game mode
00 uhr und dann bekommen wir diesen
stein
der heißt red cobblestone ganz einfach
habe ich ja schon gesagt für mich liegt
dabei eher ein bisschen nach erde aus
naja also denker der halt abbauen damit
könnt ihr dann noch ganz normal weiter
bauen blablabla bisher schon und genau
wenn wir das hier abbauen
kommt da auch ehemann dietz haus also
wie halt dieses krasse flatland habe ich
auch alles schon erwähnt die makler im
gaylord 1 und zwar könnt ihr hier die
ganzen blog finden die ihnen zugefügt
wurden wie zb hier solche sachen also
die könnt ihr so hinsetzen davon gibt es
auch verschiedene und zwar richten die
sich immer darin halt wo ihr die
hinsetzt das sind die zum beispiel von
so ein paar bäume aus dem bio was ich
glaub ja nicht so ganz kennengelernt
weil das ist von diesem angebot an
diesen anderen bäumen ist dieses hier
von diesen vier lockt also das sind
diese bäume da
außerdem könnt ihr dann wiederum war
diese ganzen sorten machen aus diesem
stein die ich ja gerade abgebaut habe
hier könnt ihr dann wieder diese sachen
weiter verarbeiten also wenig wie steps
und so weiter also da gibt es schon so
ein paar neue sachen sag ich mal die da
hinzugefügt wurden
allerdings wollte ich ja ganz gut
weitere sachen zeigen und zwar kämpfe
überall auch solche fliegenden inseln
auftreten also die hier die habe ich da
nicht so hin gebaut das war da von
anfang an so hier ist noch ein kleiner
wasser fehler als ich mach das mal in
patrick so
so wichtig das war alles was schön
runter sie doch sehr schön das alles
wirklich so eine insel ihr seht ihr
schon die neue holzart hatte ich keine
mittlere maustaste darauf machen da seht
ihr dieses vier lockt das ist das holz
was da in diesen ganzen bäumen steht
habe ich da gerade auch schon erwähnt
also solche solche dinge es hier können
auch manchmal darum stehen euch einfach
solche fliegenden insel mitten in der
pampa und naja so sieht das denn aus
wenn die um aufeinandertreffen also die
übergänge sind finde ich sehr gut
gestaltet nicht einfach so dumm ist dass
auf einmal drin sondern das geht echt
schon dass man da irgendwie hoch hüpfen
kann also grafische übergänge meine ich
jetzt gar nicht mehr so dass man da hoch
hüpfen kann und dass er auf einmal so
eine zum teil einfach so mit drin steht
also das ist schon sehr schön gestaltet
dass der ist wiederum ein ganz normales
biom also ein ganz normales fichtenholz
dichten pflichten biom keine ahnung
hier treffen gerade die beiden wieder
aufeinander also dieses dieses rote
koppel stone biom sage ich mal ich weiß
nicht genau die namen von der ich habe
auf der website nachnamen gesucht wer
den namen des bitte einfach mal nett in
die kommentare schreiben
nicht solche kommentare wie ich ja du
konntest du gar nicht vorstellbar
na ja die haben wir auch wieder normales
bier hier treffen zb ein extremes medium
und die piste aufeinander und zwar viel
ich das medium vor allem sehr geil da
haben wir zum beispiel so eine brücke
uns war es unter dem schnee wirklich
auch so wie es bei schnee halt auch oft
ist wenn er bei uns irgendwie liegt er
zu hause und das ist halt ganz cool
natürlich gucken was ein ganz klasse da
möchte ich jetzt mal eben durch
hallo da bin ich also na ja was ihm
übrigens auch in die kommentare
schreiben könnt wo wir jetzt gerade weil
schnee sind soll ich wieder ein
christmas kraft let's play machen also
für alle die schon sehr lange an und
informiert sind kennen was
wahrscheinlich noch solche das wieder
machen jetzt schon gezeigt was ich
zeigen wollte gezeigt
er wertet dafür da wäre die erde gegen
bitte einfach in die kommentare
schreiben also das ist halt dass ich an
den weihnachtstagen im dezember bis
weihnachten spiele und dann in jeder
folge hat neues bauer oder ich denke mir
etwas neues auszudenken
naja es können halt auch überall so
dörfer auftreten wie zum beispiel hier
das sieht dann teilweise ziemlich krank
aus also weil halt diese dörfer sag ich
mal normal generiert werden und dann
kommt dieser extra dazu deswegen kann es
sein dass da teilweise so ein bisschen
erde darunter ein bisschen cobblestone
unter den dörfern ist aber na ja das
sollte euch eigentlich nicht weiter
stören wird ein ganz normaler häuser
hallo
die halo der ist jetzt bis auf mich alle
gut so da und froh dass ich das gar
nicht gesehen jetzt auch noch
eingeschaltet eingeschneit das haus also
ich drücke mal kurz sieht dann seht ihr
den sieg dort und eingeblendet da ist er
also einfach mal pausieren wenn defizit
haben wollt das sind die koordinaten so
jetzt könnte das lesen wer dahin fliegen
will schreibt es nicht extra eine
beschreibung also könnt ihr auch selber
hin fliegen wenn ihr euch davon
beeinflusst das näher anschauen wollt da
haben wir zum beispiel ein williger ganz
kleinen und ganz schmachvoll naja also
dörfer sehen echt ein bisschen komisch
aus aber ich finde das komplette biom
hier einfach so mit das geilste dieses
medium das recht eis drunter ist es wenn
ich ganz cool und ich finde auch dieses
bio
dieses rote dafür nicht auch sehr geil
welt einfach was neues ist wirklich
etwas rotes gibt's noch nicht in
minecraft und na ja also das war erstmal
die vorstellung vom extra extra bis xl
motto ich weiß es seien mobbing kann man
sich schlecht vorstellen bisschen weise
sehr schlechter zu reden
deswegen wollte ich eigentlich erst nur
sachen einblenden aber naja deswegen hab
ich gedacht ich aber trotzdem ein
bisschen dazu hier unten haben haben wir
übrigens dieses birkenholz bio
das könnte ich auch noch kurz zeigen
aber es wird nicht erwähnt wird da sind
wirklich nur birken drin also ihr seht
schon
naja gut also das ist erstmal so die
vorstellung von dem extra bis xl bot ich
würde mich freuen wenn ihr dem video
einen daumen hoch geht wenn es euch
gefallen hat und dann würde ich sagen
schreibt mir das einfach in die
kommentare was ich gefragt habe also den
christmas kraft und dann sehen wir uns
beim nächsten mal tschüss